RETO MEIER: Hi there.
My name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: This week, we find
out what's up with SMS
replacement app, WhatsApp
Messenger.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We take a bite out
of the Group Me 4 beta, to
see if we like the new flavor.
RETO MEIER: Turns out it tastes
a lot less like fruit
than it used to.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And a lot
more like ice cream.
RETO MEIER: And we discover that
instant messaging classic
Trillian has not only survived
the apocalyptic instant
messaging wars of the early
2000s, but has risen from the
ashes to flourish in
the mobile space.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All that
and more, this
week on The App Clinic.
RETO MEIER: This week, we're
looking at instant messaging
apps, which turns out to be a
critical part of mine and
Ian's teamwork flow.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
What you may not realize is
Reto and I never speak
directly to one another.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In fact,
we don't even ever
be in the same room.
We're actually on opposite
sides of
building 44 right now.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Reto's not here at all.
So that means IM apps
are critical for us
to get things done.
RETO MEIER: Let's start by
looking at WhatsApp.
IAN NI-LEWIS: WhatsApp Messenger
was by far our most
popular candidate this
week, right?
RETO MEIER: Absolutely, yeah.
And you can see here that
they've done a pretty good job
on their landing page
on Google Play.
It's one of the things that
they've done a little bit
wrong here is they've got a
great logo, which I really
like to see.
But what they've done which
I think they could really
improve on is their feature
graphic, which is effectively
just a combination of their
logo, the app name, and a
bunch of screenshots.
Now, it turns out that there are
other places on the Google
Play listing for your logo, app
name, and screenshots, and
so it's kind of a
waste of space.
So they've done the right thing
in having a feature
graphic, but they could
do a lot more with
what they've got.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Sure.
RETO MEIER: So what
is this app?
It describes itself as a super
powered replacement for SMS
messaging, and I'd say
it pretty much
lives up to that claim.
It can do all of the regular
instant messaging type
behavior that you expect, which
is basically sending
instant messages to other
people, all without having to
rely on a cell network
connection in order to do so.
So the big plus here is that if
you don't have an unlimited
text messaging plan, you can
send messages to your friends
at no cost, which is nice.
As a bonus, you can also
do multimedia stuff.
So you can send pictures,
images, videos, movies, all of
that sort of stuff, which you
can theoretically do with MMS,
but this makes it
a lot easier.
And of course, it also supports
offline messaging,
which is nice.
They try and keep things as
simple as possible by tying
everything into your phone
number rather than having a
secondary account, which is
nice, but it does mean that
you can't use this app
on tablet devices.
And sure enough, they've
actually blocked installation
for those platforms, which is
a little bit disappointing,
frankly, because it
really does limit
the utility the app.
And given that it's transferring
data over the
internet, why force me to depend
on having a mobile
number and having a device
with a mobile connection?
So as you can see from this
screenshot, I think WhatsApp
Messenger could really do with
a full UI overhaul, really
bringing it up to date with
whole new themes, and
genuinely presenting a more
consistent and intuitive UI
navigation structure.
I'm not going to get too
much detail into that.
That's kind of Roman's
wheelhouse, so I'm going to
let him and the guys comment
more on that aspect on
Tuesday's Android Design
In Action.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But I think
we do have to say that
[INAUDIBLE]
is fine, but it's pretty old
school to just slap some sort
of random picture behind
your stuff.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I mean, if you're using
[INAUDIBLE]
as a technique to try and make
users more comfortable with
the app so that they feel
more familiar with the
expectations, then that's
a great idea.
Here, it just looks like, eh,
white and black backgrounds
look kind of boring.
Let's stick something behind.
Maybe a faux rock effect.
And frankly, that doesn't
really add to it.
It just makes the whole thing
look a little bit untidy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: True.
So the elevator pitch for Group
Me is that it's like
your own private Twitter.
And I think that's a pretty
accurate description.
Awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: My fault.
Sorry.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, no,
no, it's cool.
Take your time.
All right.
We've used Group Me a lot
on the Android team.
When we go to a conference like
Google I/O, it's tough to
stay in sync with
the whole team.
And if you don't stay in touch,
well, you miss things
like the $100 shots of Glen
Ross that Dan Galpin
missed at I/O 2012.
That was a good night.
And thanks, Dan.
We will pay you back someday.
Anyway, Group Me isn't perfect,
but so far, it's been
the most reliable solution for
keeping our group in sync.
It works via push messaging, but
it can also send messages
via SMS, so it works even if
you don't have a data plan.
That's pretty important if
you're in Shanghai or
Barcelona or Sao Polo.
RETO MEIER: Or the I280 between
Cupertino and Sunnyvale.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well,
that's true.
Yeah.
There's some sort of rip in
the fabric of reality down
there that disturbs anything
that gets too close.
Speaking of which, Group Me used
to look like this, which
made it feel a lot less
like an Android app.
The speech bubbles not only
make me feel like I've
accidentally picked up someone
else's device--
some hipster's device--
they also waste space and clash
with the Android action
bar at the top of the screen.
So the redesign is a better use
of space and feels a lot
more like Android.
It's even got some nice touches
like the embedded map
view, and that's great
for finding out
where the party is.
In fact, I remember in
Barcelona, we were trying to
find the party for, gee,
how long was it, Dan?
It was like, hours, right?
MALE SPEAKER: We walked
around for hours.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, and
we couldn't find it.
RETO MEIER: But in Barcelona,
everywhere's a party.
Like, just open the
nearest door.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That is true,
but we were looking for a
specific party.
MALE SPEAKER: The
great ragers.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We didn't
want to get fired.
Let's put it that way.
RETO MEIER: You didn't want to
be like Dan and miss out on
the free booze.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Well, my only objection to the
redesign is the way they've
changed the action bar.
Group Me has jumped on
the drawer bandwagon.
So not only did they take
away the regular
[? app affordance, ?]
but they've also got this three
bar thing that I guess
is starting to be acknowledged
as the universal drawer
pattern, but I'm still a fan of
the [? app affordance. ?]
And apparently they didn't get
the memo about the design
guidelines for drawers.
Just in case you're in the same
boat, here is the memo.
The main takeaway is that
drawers should slide out under
the action bar, not push the
action bar out of the way.
That's important, because your
action bar still needs to be
contextual, it's still your
[? app affordance. ?]
We don't want it to arbitrarily
leave the screen.
But let's not get too caught
up in the design.
That's really Roman's job.
Let's go ahead and move on.
Overall, the beta looks
like Group Me is
moving in a great direction.
I love the way they've
worked with media.
A lot of the recommendations
that we've given about using
larger pictures and alpha text
over the pictures just make it
look fantastic.
Honestly, the only thing that
I really, really wish that
Group Me did is an
easier login.
Now, they've actually made a
big change for the better.
In the previous version, you had
to login with your phone
number, which, for me,
was a horrible issue.
Not only do I use Google Voice
and have like 10 different
SIMs that I use--
I can never remember which phone
number I actually logged
into Group Me with first.
I think it was something that I
threw away a long time ago.
But their SMS permission system,
where they'll send you
a text to say, is this
really your phone?
It doesn't always work,
and I don't know why.
RETO MEIER: I had that problem
today, actually.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It might be that because of
their beta, the servers are
just under load or something.
Anyway, they made it so you can
log in with a username and
password, but if you've been
watching the show, you know
what my pet peeve is here.
Don't make me type in a
username and password.
My credentials are
on the phone.
Either put the account on the
phone, or synchronize or
federate with an account
that's already there.
Google Play services
makes this easy.
We talked about that
a couple weeks ago.
Typing in passwords
is so 2010.
Don't make me do it.
All right, let's go
ahead and move on.
RETO MEIER: All right.
So I think the biggest surprise
for me with Trillian
is that it actually still
existed, and I mean that as
kind of a compliment.
It's great to see a company able
to leverage their core
strengths and really take
advantage of new opportunities
when they arrive.
And that's really exactly what
the team at Trillian has done.
So in the height of the instant
messaging federation
wars, Trillian was my go to
client for being able to
connect to multiple
services at once.
I was on ICQ, I had friends
who were on--
what other ones existed?
Yahoo?
I don't know.
There was a bunch.
IAN NI-LEWIS: AOL.
RETO MEIER: AOL.
Yeah.
There was heaps of them.
And so Trillian was a great way
to have one app that lived
on my desktop PC at that time
that let me communicate with
everyone, because that was the
only way we could get things
done was to have clients do
the federation for us.
Now, these days, they've taken
it a step further, and they've
added support for some of the
newer protocols like Facebook
instant messaging, I think Skype
is either there or on
their roadmap.
And of course, with most of
these conversations now
happening from people's phones,
it's great to see
Trillian offering
a mobile app.
So rather than being a
replacement for SMS messaging
like the two apps that we looked
at earlier, Trillian is
really looking to replace the
need for having a number of
separate chat clients for each
different services that you
already use.
So it's supposed to replace
having to have four or five
different instant messaging
clients.
And they've done a great job of
keeping things simple, and
you can see that on the
screenshot here.
And as you go through the app,
it really is sort of that cut
down, most basic vision of
how instant messaging
apps used to work.
You have a list of contacts, in
this case separated by the
service type, so you can see
who your ICQ friends are--
which kind of doesn't make that
much sense, because I
don't really care what
technology I'm using, what
back end service I'm using to
communicate with people.
I just want to see the people
and communicate with them.
And I guess the complexity here
is that often people will
have multiple accounts on each
of the different services, so
how do you reconcile that?
I think that's one of the
challenges, and something
which an app like Trillian could
really perhaps put in a
little bit more effort to figure
out how to do that
reconciliation.
Otherwise, the simplicity is
nice, but really the app just
looks a little dated.
It could really do an upgrade
to hollow styling.
And even better, I'd really
love to see them try and
develop a rich tablet user
experience to complement their
desktop and mobile apps.
So again, this is an app which
was designed for mobile to
take advantage of the fact that
people were sending their
instant messages over SMS via
BlackBerry Messenger and other
mobile devices, and so they've
made a mobile app as well.
I'd love to see them now realize
that tablets are where
it's at as well, and develop
some tablet app features too.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It feels like one
of those things where they
could really take advantage
of the content manager.
If you think about it, having
people that have ICQ and
Facebook and other different
types of accounts is really
just like having a friend that
has a work phone and a home
phone and a cell phone, right?
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And that's exactly what the
contacts contract content
provider lets you do.
So you can add your own specific
content types.
And in this case, it
would be different
instant messaging clients.
And if I'm not mistaken, I
think instant messaging
clients is one of the default
fields you can use.
So they may be better off just
leveraging that existing
infrastructure.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Definitely.
I think that would make
me a lot happier.
Although it always makes me
happy whenever you have to say
contracts contacts contracts
provider on air.
You can do it better
than I do.
RETO MEIER: Well, you know,
it's all about practice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So let's go ahead
and dive into a couple
of details that we think
would help instant
messaging apps in general.
If I had to pick one feature
that is absolutely crucial for
an instant messaging app, that
one thing that you really just
cannot afford to get wrong
is notifications.
The whole point of instant
messaging is it's instant.
You need to know as soon
as a message arrives.
At the same time, it's
also crucial to use
notifications wisely.
It's terrible to have too
many notifications.
It's worse than having
none at all.
So that's why on any version
of Android, no matter what
you're running, you should
always make sure you're doing
what we call stacking
notifications.
I sort of don't like the word
stacking notifications,
because it could actually refer
to the wrong way of
doing things, in my opinion.
But here's what the design guide
means when we talk about
stacking notifications.
If you have two notifications
that would otherwise be
displayed on top of one another,
the basic rule of
thumb is that your app should
never appear more than once in
the notification panel.
So if you have something new
to say, then say it inside
your existing notification,
rather than creating a second
notification.
For instance, you could add a
number pending field to let
your users know that there's
more to see.
Instead of placing three
notifications in the
notification panel, you just
display one that says you have
three notifications pending.
But if you're running on
Jellybean or higher, you can
actually do a lot better
than that.
The standard notification
builder class has a new style.
It's called [? index ?]
style, and it lets you add
a list of strings to your
notification.
So when the notification gets
expanded, the user can see all
their recent notifications
at a glance.
You can see that in the Gmail
app, for instance.
And I think if you look at this
particular style, the
view on the right there where
it's expanded, I think you can
see that's a perfect
way to receive a
series of instant messages.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You might also
consider going one step
further with rich notifications
and have some
action buttons.
For instance, I honestly would
really appreciate a button to
automatically send
a busy message
for all my IM buddies--
you know, I'm driving,
or whatever.
Just something that's really,
really simple.
RETO MEIER: Or if I'm
in a meeting.
Something slightly
less dangerous.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
Well, anyway, the point is that
there's a lot of stuff
that you can do with rich
notifications on Jellybean.
But you don't actually
have to be targeting
Jellybean to get this.
If you use a notification
[? compat ?]
API, it's easiest to support
both the old notification
style and the new hotness.
Just remember that any action
buttons you create won't be
available on legacy versions of
the OS, so you need to have
some alternate way to access
that behavior.
And of course, as we all know,
it's usually to just tap the
notification and send the user
directly to an activity that
can handle that notification or
expand on or offer actions.
RETO MEIER: So using the
notification [? compat ?]
API, you're actually able to
just have a single code path
which has all the functionality
for all the
newest versions, and then it
just gracefully degrades back
to whatever is supported?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Essentially
so, yes.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Oh, that's quite handy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So that's really cool.
So the code that you see on the
screen is ripped from the
pages of developer.android.com,
and it
shows you exactly how to make
an inbox style notification.
As you can see, it's really
quite simple.
RETO MEIER: And I think, in
fact, if you go to Android
training, or perhaps the API
guides, the notification
guide, I think, has been
recently updated to have all
of the new hotness explained
in some detail.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes, in fact,
that's where I stole all the
previous [INAUDIBLE]
graphics from.
RETO MEIER: Outstanding.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes.
I have been thieving like
a madman today.
RETO MEIER: That's what we do
here as developer advocates.
We take all the hard work of
our tech writers, and steal
it, and pass it off
as our own.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Ah, life is good.
Well, what do you have
for us today, Reto?
RETO MEIER: Well, I think it's
also worth discussing how
these instant messaging
apps actually work.
The key to a great experience
is really balancing that low
latency instant instant
messaging with making sure
that you're not draining the
battery in order to get those
rapid updates.
So fundamentally, there's a
couple of different approaches
that you can take.
On the first hand, you can
maintain an open socket
connection between your client
running on each device and
your server.
Now, having an open socket will
minimize your latency,
because the connection
is there.
You can just send stuff
through that pipe.
But you really need to carefully
manage it so that
you're not draining your battery
exceptionally quickly
by maintaining that socket.
So the way that you actually
keep the socket open is by
sending data or sending
[INAUDIBLE]
pings to your server at regular
intervals, which is
going to stop the network
from automatically
closing those sockets.
But if you ping too regularly,
you're just going to be
keeping the cell radio
turned on.
It's just going to drain
the battery.
And if you do it too
infrequently, you're going to
lose your socket connection
anyway.
So the latency's going to go up,
because you're expecting
it to be zero latency,
but it isn't.
You've got the additional cost
it takes to initiate a new
socket connection.
It's just a bad time
all around.
And figuring out the right
frequency is actually really,
really hard.
It varies between network
operators--
the sockets that you're allowed
to use to have these
long, looped connections vary
depending on networks.
So it makes it really difficult
for individual app
developers to figure out.
And frankly, that's not the sort
of thing that you want to
have to be thinking about.
You want to be focusing on
features, on UI, not how do I
keep the data connection going
between the app and server.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, not only
that, but even if you got
everything right, in order to
avoid draining the battery and
keep the socket open and get
all the behavior that you
want, you would also have to
synchronize perfectly with any
other app that wanted
to do this, right?
Because even if-- let's say 10
minutes is the magic number.
My app goes every 10
minutes, your app
goes every 10 minutes.
Your app started five
minutes after mine.
Ouch.
RETO MEIER: Whoopsie.
So can we do that, then?
How can we synchronize all of
the apps on the device so that
they all send pings
at the same time?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, I think
you've got to have somebody
send the pings for you.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And happily, that is
exactly what Google
Cloud Messaging does.
So we've already figured out
the most efficient way to
maintain a low latency network
path, and in fact, this is
something that we can keep
track of and continue to
optimize and make more and more
efficient, so that you
can just piggyback on top
of that, and use it as a
mechanism to tell your app when
it should initiate a new
connection and start
transferring those
messages in real time.
So all the details for Google
Cloud Messaging are available
on that cloud sync Android
training class.
So the thing is, though, that
cloud to device messaging or
C2DM, as we like to call it,
because everyone loves an
acronym, doesn't guarantee
the delivery latency.
It will definitely get there,
but you don't know that it'll
get there straight away.
Now, chances are it will get
there straight away.
But one approach, too, is
actually use C2DM to initiate
the conversation.
So when someone pings you with
a message the first time, use
see C2DM to notify the
recipient, who can then create
a short lived socket connection
to transfer the
rapid fire messages backwards
and forwards.
So then you're just keeping
a short lived socket.
You kill it as soon as the
conversation is finished, and
then fall back to waiting for
C2DM to wake up your app and
listen for new messages.
So some apps that we looked at
actually chose to use a third
option, which isn't really
an option, which
is polling the server--
just pinging your server to
check to see whether you've
got any new messages pending.
And that's kind of a terrible
idea, because the latency is
going to be shocking, unless
you're doing it every minute,
in which case the battery drain
is going to be even more
shocking than the latency.
And I saw some comments in
reviews suggesting that that's
what WhatsApp Messenger does
to get its messages.
I haven't confirmed that, so I
don't want to criticize them
too sharply without knowing
for certain.
But if that is the case, then
that's definitely something
you want to move away from and
move towards a GCM model.
So if you have your own service,
polling is never the
right answer.
So if you're relying on someone
else's service to get
information so you can't send a
push message, well, OK, then
you're going to have to come
up with something clever.
But if you've got your own
servers, then this is going to
make your life a lot easier.
So yes.
Switch to GCM.
The sun will shine brighter,
food will taste sweeter, and
life will always be better.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I switched
to GCM.
I liked it so much I
bought the company.
RETO MEIER: So before we sign
off, let's take a look at
prescriptions for each of the
apps that we have looked at
today, and see if we cannot help
them move towards a more
pure Android experience.
So let's start off with
WhatsApp Messenger.
So I think first off, what
I'd really like to
see is tablet support.
I'd love to see them make this
app work really nicely, create
an optimized tablet
experience.
I think that's something which
is kind of missing from this
space, where a lot of the focus
has been on creating
this awesome mobile experience,
because that's
clearly where their growth is.
Tablets seem like the
next logical step.
When you're sitting on the
couch, rather than opening up
your laptop to instant messaging
people, you can have
a richer experience talking
to more than one
person using a tablet.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I was surprised at
how common it was for some
of these messaging apps to rely
on SMS if not as their
only transport mechanism,
then at least as
their primary mechanism.
And that really feels
like five years ago.
RETO MEIER: It does.
It kind of made sense back when,
hey, we can simplify
signup by just checking what
the phone number is.
But now it actually complicates
it, because half
of my devices don't have
a SIM card in them.
I've got tablets, I've got some
devices without SIMs, so
it really just makes
my life harder.
So a non-phone signup flow for
WhatsApp Messenger would make
my life a lot better.
I'd love to see a
modernized UI.
I'd love to see some using cloud
to device messaging, if
they're not already doing so.
Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In the
future, none of us
will have phone numbers.
You're going to be able to
ring my email address.
RETO MEIER: I would
like to do that.
That would make me
a happier person.
What did you think
about Group Me?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, Group Me is
in beta, and the beta looks
really, really promising.
It's hard to say for sure
exactly how it's
going to turn out.
You know there's definitely
some rough
edges right now, but--
RETO MEIER: Sure.
But we like the idea of beta
releases to try and figure out
where you should be investing
that time and effort to get
the best bang for your
buck, right?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
In fact, the only thing that
disappointed me about the beta
is I couldn't get it
off of Google Play.
I had to go to their
website and get it.
But that's not their fault.
That's probably ours.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
It would be nice if we offered a
way to do a more streamlined
beta release by Google
Play, but--
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what?
I'll put in a request.
RETO MEIER: Let's do that.
I know some people.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The drawer pattern
is definitely done in,
let's say, not the
wrong way, but--
it's the wrong way.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's not the way
that we recommend right now.
And so I'd like to see
them fix that.
They also have this sort of--
we didn't really touch on
this, but they've got this sort
of weird thing where the
drawer actually opens either to
the left or to the right,
making it almost, but not
quite like a view pager.
So they've sort of mixed a few
metaphors, and I think that as
they sort of hone in on their
final version, they might want
to take a look at that and
decide whether the user
confusion is going to be worth
the benefits they're
getting out of it.
RETO MEIER: It's just a really
interesting example as well,
where given that it is in beta,
there's an opportunity
there to do some AB testing and
just sort of pick one or a
few different options presented
to different users,
and use analytics to figure
out which is the one that
people are finding the
easiest to use?
So I'm a big fan of doing that,
particularly in beta.
If you've got a bunch of
alternate ideas, present them
all, and see which one users
actually use and
find the most intuitive.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But especially
coming from their last
version, which is, as I said, a
service that we used a lot.
We've always enjoyed using the
app, but design wise, this is
head and shoulders above
the other one.
So hopefully they'll converge
onto something that everybody
loves, and will get all
that figured out.
The other thing, of course, and
this pretty much applies
to almost any app that has any
kind of login is let's
integrate that sign in.
If you're not going to do with
Google, then integrate with
something else.
Facebook's popular, Twitter is
fine, anything where the user
is likely to have an account
on the machine.
For Android, we usually suggest
Google, not because
that's who pays us, although
it sort of is.
But because almost all Android
devices have a
Google account on them.
RETO MEIER: I mean, really, what
we're just trying to do
is make that sign in flow as
simple as possible, and it's
something that we're
particularly sensitive to,
because we install
a lot of apps.
And we're doing this, and the
App Clinic, obviously, we
spend a fair bit of
time looking at.
But we spend a lot of time
looking at a lot of apps, and
we do it really quickly.
We download it, we'll open it
up, and we want to figure out
how this app works, what it's
doing right, what it's doing
wrong, inside of 15 seconds.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, I
don't think we're
unique in that, because--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's very, very
common, if a user wants to
download an app for a particular
purpose, it's
extremely common to download
10 of them.
And the ones that are going to
get looked at first are the
ones that don't throw up any
roadblocks to finding out what
the functionality is.
Now, Group Me is an app that
I love a lot, but I think I
probably would have skipped it
at the beginning, because I
couldn't get into the app until
I had not only put in my
phone number, but verified it
with an SMS which I never got.
Now, fortunately they've fixed
that particular flaw, but you
still have to sign in before you
can get to the good stuff.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And this is something which
actually I can see for next
week, we're doing personal
fitness apps.
And I actually discovered this
exact scenario where I was
sitting at the foot of the
mountain, ready to go hiking,
my wife's like, we should
track how far we go.
I think I have an
app for that.
So I fired up the [? trailer, ?]
looked at all
the suggestions, and installed
each of them.
And the way I chose which one to
use was I just opened them
one at a time, and as soon as
I got to a roadblock, I
stopped to check if the
other one was quicker.
It's like, you need
me to sign in?
No.
You need me to do a
bunch of settings?
No.
And that's kind of the way
people use their apps.
They're going, I need
to do something.
I'm going to download an
app and see whether it
does that for me.
It's not the, yeah, I've
got some time.
I'm going to download this app
and see what it does and see
how it works.
It's not really the use case
particularly on mobile.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And we're being
a little unfair, because
obviously, in an instant
messaging situation, you have
to sign in in some way.
RETO MEIER: Have an identity?
IAN NI-LEWIS: But that's why
it's so important to federate
or integrate with the context
manager and the account
manager on the device.
Now, I will say in Group Me's
favor that their new beta, if
you don't sign in immediately,
still has a view pager with
some demo screens on it, and
it kind of tells you what
you're getting into.
So I think that's a good effort,
but still, if I can
just open it up and it
automatically knew,
oh, you're this guy.
I think I've seen you before.
That would make me
super happy.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And keep in mind as well that
even without doing the
federated sign in that Ian's
describing, you can tell me
what my phone number is by
checking the phone, and you
can tell me what my email
address is by
checking the phone.
So populating those and asking
me to confirm them, rather
than having me type them all
in is all things which are
going to make that sign
in process smoother.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
So what did you think
about Trillian?
RETO MEIER: Trillian.
So kind of similar to the first
app that we looked at,
in that I'd really like to see
a modernized UI and improved
tablet support.
I think otherwise, it's good in
that it has that focus, and
so that's a big thing
for me is an app
which has a clear focus.
And in this app, they're not
trying to reinvent messaging.
They're just trying to make it
easy for you to use the tools
and the services and the
contacts that you've already
been communicating with on
a different platform.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, and I guess
it's not showing up here
because this slide was put
together by trained monkeys,
but the real important thing,
I think, is that they could
integrate with contacts
manager.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
I've already got my
contacts there.
Put all of that data in there,
and that's going to make life
a lot easier.
So basically, Trillian's been
around for a long time, and so
that's why I think tablet
support is a big one for them.
It's like, it's a company which
clearly recognizes that
there's an opportunity in
adapting their service to
people using new devices.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But let's
adapt all the way.
Let's make it-- by the way,
you didn't put this slide
together, did you?
RETO MEIER: No no, that was
my trained monkeys.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh good.
RETO MEIER: They're
getting there.
I mean, this is close.
This is two out of three.
I'm pretty happy with that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Sure.
Good point.
RETO MEIER: Right.
So I think we've just
done half an hour.
We've managed to keep it to the
time frame that we were
hoping to this week,
so yay us.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yay!
RETO MEIER: That's
all for us today.
Don't forget to tune in to
Roman, Nick, and Adam for
Android Design in Action, next
Tuesday, from the unflooded
New York office, where they'll
be setting their design skills
loose on some of the instant
messaging apps that we talked
about today.
RETO MEIER: And I think they
said they're going to be
looking at [? Trippit ?]
as well.
RETO MEIER: Oh, excellent.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I was just talking to Roman, and
then he said he had to go,
because he was on the
phone with a--
and then he used a nasty word.
RETO MEIER: Oh, that's
surprising.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know why?
New York.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
New Yorkers, man.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway, we'll be
back next week, taking a look
at personal fitness
tracking apps.
RETO MEIER: And the voting in
that category has been fierce,
so be sure to hit our trailer
page and get your votes and
nominations in for this week
and the following weeks.
There's a bit.ly link there at
bit.ly/appclinic/trailer.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, remember
to vote early.
Don't be like the people who
nominated poor Glyph, which
received the most votes this
week, but was nominated too
late to be considered.
RETO MEIER: We'll try
and squeeze Glyph
into another week.
But until then, here's a quick
message to tide you over.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Pencil, square,
skull, skull, skull, diamond,
airplane, pencil.
RETO MEIER: Nice one.
Until then, I'm Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: And thank
you for watching.